what's up everybody its Warren and if
you thought that the future of
spider-man in the MCU was still at
jeopardy just because Disney and Sony
only worked out a - movie deal I'm here
to tell you that you don't need to worry
because it appears that spider-man is
going to be remaining in the MCU for a
pretty long time and he's going to be
bringing his buddy venom right now
shooting for venom two has begun and
recently the producer for venom 2 has
teased a crossover between venom and
spider-man and based off of what he said
it looks like it's going to be pretty
big so I'll break down exactly what he
said in this video I'm still doing it
Xbox one and ps4 giveaway all you have
to do to enter is subscribe with
notifications turned on like the video
and leave a comment down below venom -
producer and a longtime spider-man
producer Matt Tomac was recently
interviewed about venom - in which he
was asked some questions about
spider-man as well and in this interview
he was asked about the director Tom
Hardy and Tom Hollands spider-man in the
interview when speaking about the
director for venom 2 Andy Serkis he said
he's a great director but also he's an
actor and he's played inside monsters
and he sort of understands characters
from inside
it's been wild to watch him with Hardy
because they speak that language that
only actors understand particularly
people like Tom Hardy and what it's like
to be in this other character from
another realm
he's like a mystical figure Andy Serkis
and when he's around people you feel his
presence he was having Tom do really
well and so we got to know him actually
through Tom he's going to be special
it's a really great connection so right
away right off the bat it sounds like
venom 2 is shaping out to be very well
with its new director Andy Serkis but of
course as expected he was also asked
when we could possibly see a meeting
between Tom Hardy's venom and Tom
Hollands spider-man something that we
know that Sony Pictures is very keen on
and although he did not offer much he
did say we have big plans so there you
have it right there coming directly from
a venom - producer and a longtime
spider-man producer he's just confirmed
that there are in fact big plans for the
two characters to crossover in a
crossover event so for everybody who has
just been waiting for this to happen
spider-man vs. venom don't worry it is
going to happen and that is coming
directly from a producer at Sony
now the other question is where exactly
will this happen will it happen on
Sony's ground or will it happen in the
MCU well although right now it is
unclear we do know that the new deal
between Sony and Disney was for a
spider-man solo film and a spider-man
crossover film now of course it's
probably going to be a crossover with
somebody else in the MCU however we have
absolutely no idea what went down in
these renegotiations for the spider-man
contract but what we do know is that
Sony does in fact want venom in the MCU
it was actually Marvel that was hesitant
about having venom in the MCU in the
first place there have been several
reports that Sony wants venom in the MCU
in fact before the renegotiations for
spider-man still began there was reports
from credible sources stating that Sony
actually wanted venom in spider-man 3 in
the MCU so with the new contract for
spider-man perhaps this is something
that we could see because we know that
Marvel wants to keep Tom Hollands
spider-man in the MCU no matter what so
perhaps with that deal came a deal for
venom to crossover as well either way we
are going to see a Tom Holland and a Tom
Hardy spider-man venom crossover let me
know what you think about this and let
me know would you like this to be in the
MCU or would you like it to be in Sony's
spider-verse leave your thoughts down
below also don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on and like the
video to enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 if you would
like a chance to win an Infinity
Gauntlet and some G fuel click the link
in the description down below and don't
forget to use code cosmic when you check
out at G field comm as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof